Cinema may be a visual medium but
there's a reason movies didn't stay
silent for long sound teams transform
images into fully dimensional Moments by
designing recording mixing and editing
everything you hear yeah and we mean
everything sure the Batmobile it sounds
awesome but someone has to figure out
what Batman's garage door sounds like
that's right okay and someone also has
to make F-18 sound kind of f18ish right
totally and and and who decides what a
navi braid sounds like when it hits the
water I've wondered that
um well
ah I just found out these amazing
artists these amazing artists here are
the nominees for achievement and sound
All Quiet on the Western Front Victoria
crosso
Marcus Steiner Lars ginsel and Stefan
corta Avatar the way of water Julian
Howard Gwendolyn gateswiddle dick
Bernstein Christopher boys Gary Summers
and Michael Hedges the Batman Stuart
Wilson William fives Douglas Murray and
Andy Nelson Elvis David Lee Wayne
pashley Andy Nelson and Michael Keller
top gun Maverick Mark Weingarten James H
Mather Al Nelson Chris burden and Mark
Taylor
and the Oscar goes to
top gun Maverick
[Applause]
[Music]
team behind Top Gun Mavericks spanned
two continents and created much of the
sound design by reporting real aircraft
carriers and jet engines
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Academy and thank you to
everyone who saw and heard this film
together in theaters
thank you to our incredibly
collaborative filmmakers our director
Joe Kaczynski and our producer Sherry
brookheimer Tom Cruise Tommy Harper
Chris mcquarie
thank you to the sound artists who share
this award with us at Skywalker sound
Bjorn Chris Gary and her Twickenham and
sound bite studios in London thank you
to our families Mom Dad Julie Adam Aiden
Zach and Raquel
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you